hello everybody my name is markiplier
and hang on a second listen to this
music ha ha I love it but then again
maybe I just lie like classical music so
this is actually pretty impressive so
anyway welcome to let's play packed with
a demon chapter 1 now this is a game
that I found on indie BB it wasn't
recommended to me or maybe it was a tour
I didn't see it but it seems like it's
got a lot of potential because there's a
lot of work put into it which I really
really appreciate and even that's a
French version if you speak French so
let's get right into the game history
Richard Benjamin abran mark Paul and
Antonio six of men of different ages
medieval World War two
nowadays and even the future I've once
made a pact with the demon aber baton to
get the thing they want most in the
world
you wonder why Richard wanted to be rich
a week after the pact to get a good job
a nice car a beautiful wife in a
beautiful home he had succeeded in his
life but soon he will understand that
this gift was poison one day or another
this man will give his life the garbha
get another other injury but return home
after work huh press Pacey continue
alright then I guess we're going now
okay
dark devil company oh this is the intro
sequence out really cool yeah like I was
saying when I saw this game it looked
like there was actually quite a bit of
work put into it so I'm actually pretty
impressed by it by the French youtuber
bast craft so I'm actually pretty
excited to be playing this because it's
not often when an indie game comes along
that actually has a good bit of work put
into it so I'm pretty interested in this
inspired by the game slender so I hope
that's it okay then haha what happened
there I'm hoping this isn't just another
slender clone oh I gotta choose my
difficulty really
now let's go for a challenge not too
much of a challenge
I mean I'm pro at all but I don't want
to stress myself you know my gaming
skills don't need to be tested that's
significantly hello okay press escape to
put the MAME on pause in to view the
controls I pretty much every configured
Oh No
my Hot Wheels car it's been wrecked
crashed no my car is completely dead
scheisse or whatever [ __ ] means in
French to them guessing this is made by
a Frenchman which is pretty cool
I have nothing against the French -
beautiful language okay anyway Chris ear
left click to get an object what is that
what is that is that ok alright whatever
see uh your left clicked wait okay I
took it but how do I read it
Oh tab demonic objects a Scala book of
sward a head of a statue of the devil a
red blood potion and a bone I'll give
you a bone what is it oh it's a fountain
oh I could have sworn that was
Slenderman it looked like it with the
white part up done never mind I am okay
uh-huh
starting off a little early are you I'm
gonna go in the way that you didn't go
let's just say that right now alright
can i sprint yes I can I'm usually
pretty bad about finding out if I can
sprint or not right away it is dark in
these wood what why what happened I
didn't see anything you just got a
randomly is that string quartet on my
back again it better not be so I uh shy
alright anyway so let's just keep I
don't know if I can run out of Sprint
juice here but I'll try huh-huh-huh-huh
I'm just breathing a little hard just
gotta breathe huh dawn Clara Claus with
a little lot of scriptable running was
that oh that's the ocean I think okay
yeah it's the ocean over there
oh hello wait I saw something yeah I saw
something there's a fire okay fire of
what what's on fire why is it on fire
why did I crash in
a barrier in the middle of what wasn't I
headed home how could I be
Wow that is that was pretty cool but why
is it on fire and why is it in the
middle of park Oh red potion
well that's promising okay good huh
thank you I'll just take this and be
honest yeah okay I'll just take this and
be on my way thank you very much uh-huh
okay if this is anything like the
Slender map it's gonna be a big circle
filled with multiple landmarks so I
think I found the first landmark with
the first item so I just got to keep
going until I find more landmarks
hopefully they'll be as obvious as a
giant burning Tower
huh all right then I'm just a little my
character so scared
stop being shut up baby suck it up and
get going okay it's another landmark
hello
it's a lamppost
boy this Park has inadequate lighting
all right let me I'm just gonna keep
going on the right paths until I am
forced to go left that way I'm trying to
hit the outskirts of it because the
strategy I got no stars to guide me it's
pretty dark but the strategy that I did
in the Slender game was uh you know I
tried to go around the map first but
that was probably dumb that's by why I
didn't when I saw something there you
can't fool me I saw that you can't fool
me what happened I saw it was oh hello
what is that what's that oh whoa whoa
whoa whoa whoa whoa who's that a
spotlight do I just trigger an alarm
who's that
what is that oh it's a lighthouse oh no
hi hi
are you wait hang on I needed a head of
a statue of the devil
can I take yup I can take you okay
all right so all I need from you that's
really cool by the way it's like it just
a spotlight gonna go around okay um
where's this go okay that's the ocean
more woods there it's pretty dense
forest I kind of like that okay still
going on the rightmost but was it Oh
down another lamppost okay
I think these lamp people hide me
why are you by me
why are you behind me
uh uh okay Herman I'll keep going huh
keep running what is that what is that
what is that ah that's what I was gonna
keep running though what is that oh it's
a monster duty daddy Adam it's a monster
duty daddy you heard me right don't
question my words okay there's a
lamppost with a barrel okay doesn't seem
to be very fast right now but then again
I've only got two objects uh-huh oh
there's a monster in these woods that I
need to avoid huh all right all right
all right all right it's quite a claws
it's gonna win this one don't know why
oh hello what is this some sort of water
tank I don't think I should stop running
this looks like another landmark though
see what else did I need I got the
statue head and the red blood potion so
what's here sometimes I found you
ha oh hello wait wait a bone wait yeah
just a bone that's right that's what I
need right yeah yeah you got three whoa
is that there before okay whatever I got
three don't care don't care to fab don't
care I'm gonna win this huh on hardmode
who's that I heard something what is
that I heard some can't fool me
I've been abandoned on all your clues I
can tell I can tell when something's
happening I'm smarter than I look and I
look where what where where where we
were where where what why when where why
what who how I hear little noises as I'm
breathing heavily well I'm just keep
taking the rightmost pass hopefully
they'll leave me haha what is this is
this or something this is a something hi
hey now
nunna what is this it's in French
Jeff's we born Millau what does that say
I can't pick it up aha
second day I made a campfire warm up and
II am very scared I heard noises
stronger approach me this is my last
medicine Benjamin who's Benjamin another
one of the guys that did the thing
mysterious SOS why this is here no well
no come on oh come on I was gonna read
that never mind I guess hopefully tell
me you guys can pause that quick enough
alright let's go there we go alright I
think it's you this might be the one I
got a feeling that this is the only one
here I gotta cross the bridge again and
go bad the matter it's a matter can walk
on water why why is everything is it a
water skipper Roger okay anyway I'm
still taking the rightmost pass hoping I
can fit another landmark before I circle
back to the beginning don't think that
thing isn't very fast okay what's this
oh good a building I want to go in as a
command bunker ah hell nice music in the
background there I guess oh my god what
happened here no no the problem
so you see a black silhouette in the
forest I hear footsteps until somebody
needle meter mark me oh no no not me
okay I need to get out of here oh I
think I'm gonna make it I got five of
six Mike turning right strategies going
very well
surprisingly well yeah this is really
hard
oh so the claws would not impress while
you're okay wait hang on I'm still gonna
go right but I have a feeling that once
I get back to the fountain I'm gonna go
take that Center path because there's
probably something in the center i Ju
Oh God hi that's the fountain I thought
that was the monitoring that this
fountain is scared me more than anything
else in this game okay I'm gonna go down
the center path ha ha ha ha I shop
everybody I wasn't scared that was just
ha shut up
not funny okay anyway so if I go down
the center there's probably gonna be
something in the center of the map now I
don't know how to escape after I get
there but whatever hello Oh My glob many
old building this area is completely
devastated I have to get leave which
fastest possible okay but not before I
found a thing oh it is that a thing that
a thing that looks like you're saying a
god ha
gimme god damn it give me the thing ah
ah dad why this version will be
ameliorated soon yeah a guy alright who
dated by dark devil company by bass crap
not bad well done game um the only
criticism I could possibly say is um
you could have done a lot more with that
monster that monster could have been a
lot more threatening but other than that
that was really well made I mean it was
pretty cool you had separate landmarks
I'm a few jump scares some of them
pretty cheap but you know you can always
you improve it but
I mean if this is just chapter one I'm
gonna hang on I'm gonna get out of this
because okay back to this this awesome
intro music I like this one I'd not just
skip the the the the ton amazing but
sometimes people put in copyrighted
music in the end times I don't want to
god I'll get any trouble that so anyway
so this has been great this is a great
star for your first indie game this is
way better than some of the games I've
played I mean I have played some bad
ones for people's first try this is
really well done you got a lot of
potential here so keep going I'll play
the next chapters no problem because it
said there was like five people so I
would love to see the other stories just
get a little more creative with it
you know can uh it doesn't have to
always be collecting objects or
something it could just be like you know
not trying to find an exit or something
like that or something you know you got
a lot potential your great great job on
this try so thank you all so much for
watching click the annotation for more
videos that I've done and as always I
will see you in the next video
god
Wow
ah
Oh